[Música]
India está a punto de convertirse en el
país más poblado del mundo y superar Por
poco los 1.425 millones de habitantes
que tiene China además las estimaciones
del fondo de población de Naciones
Unidas apuntan a que las tendencias Son
opuestas Pues mientras en China decrece
la cantidad de personas en India este
número va al alza Esto fue lo que dijo
el organismo de la ONU
se prevé que India supere a China como
el país más poblado del mundo durante el
mes actual de abril de 2023 la población
de China alcanzó su tamaño máximo de
1.400 millones en 2022 y ha empezado a
disminuir
las proyecciones indican que el tamaño
de la población de China podría caer por
debajo de mil millones antes de fin de
siglo en India por contrario se espera
que la población continúe creciendo
durante varias décadas
Pero por qué importa esto primero es un
hecho histórico porque es es la primera
vez en décadas que china no será el país
más poblado y segundo porque a medida
que crece la población India la gran
pregunta es que tanto podrá convertirse
este país en un gran poder global y si
en algún momento podrá superar o no a
los chinos pero no es un reto nada fácil
por la desigualdad y la pobreza que
impera en territorio indio aún así
podría convertirse India en la próxima
fábrica del mundo por encima de China y
que tanto le benefician sus buenas
relaciones con occidente para hacer una
opción a quienes no confíen en los
chinos para analizar este tema aquí en
el debate nos acompaña desde Buenos
Aires Lía Rodríguez de la Vega ella es
licenciada en estudios orientales y
doctora en relaciones internacionales
antes de comenzar con ella les quiero
recordar a ustedes nuestros televidentes
que también hacen parte de nuestro
programa pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram nos encuentran como arroba
franz24-raya al piso es y pueden
comentar con la etiqueta numeral el
debate f-24 a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como arroba María Aguirre y no
olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y TuneIn
quiero entonces para comenzar darle la
bienvenida a Lía Gracias por estar con
nosotros y la pregunta inicial es Cuáles
son las primeras consecuencias de que
India pueda alcanzar los 1.400 millones
de habitantes versus los
1.425 millones de habitantes que hay en
China
bueno en primer lugar Muchas gracias por
la convocatoria un verdadero gusto yo
diría que la primera expectativa que hay
de este de esta diferencia de esta
superación de India sobre la población
de China tiene en primera instancia una
proyección económica verdad India tiene
en este momento alrededor del 27% de su
población entre 15 y 29 años y un
poquito menos del 50% entre 15 y 40 años
eso es una población muy joven India
tiene lo que se denomina un bonus
demográfico Entonces si India logra
efectivamente educarlos y hacerlos
competitivos en el mercado internacional
esto puede significar una diferencia
enorme en términos de su crecimiento
económico y creo que es aquello hacia lo
cual están apostando verdad en un
momento además en que todos debemos ver
con mucha Claridad la intención que
India tiene de proyección propia en el
mundo este año ellos ocupan la
presidencia del g-20 pero también la
presidencia de la Organización de
cooperación de Shanghai lo cual trae una
enorme exposición y una gran un gran
movimiento al interior de India y en la
región en torno de esa proyección
y le propongo que hagamos un comparativo
demográfico entre las situaciones de
China y de India porque tal como usted
lo mencionó uno de los grandes bonus que
tiene India Es que la mayor parte de su
población es una población joven que
está en edad de producir contrario a lo
que ocurre en China donde la población
es más que todo mayor de los 50 y los 60
años y de igual manera la natalidad en
India ha aumentado un poco
progresivamente mientras que la de China
está decreciendo al respecto si bien en
India los cálculos de maternidad por
ejemplo y de nacimiento están cayendo ya
las mujeres no tienen en promedio cinco
hijos como lo hacían en 1950 sino ya dos
hijos esto aún así sigue creciendo la
población Mientras que el año pasado
2022 china por primera vez en seis
décadas registró un decrecimiento de su
población Cuáles son las implicaciones
de estas tendencias
Bueno yo creo que en primer lugar lo que
tenemos que tener presente es que se han
aplicado políticas poblacionales
diferentes no nosotros debemos recordar
que china ha tenido aquella famosa
política de un solo hijo no aplicada a
toda la población pero si una gran parte
de ella Desde 1979 y que en 2015 se
discontinuó pero cuando se discontinuó
había ya ocasionado toda una serie de
efectos que son importantes
en principio crearon una cultura de un
solo hijo que es muy difícil de remontar
lleva mucho tiempo porque las parejas
casadas se han hecho a la idea de que es
mejor tener un solo hijo en paralelo con
distintas cosas que van sucediendo
en ambos países la educación de la mujer
la participación más activa de las
mujeres en la fuerza laboral a pesar de
que esto en India Todavía es muy bajo no
solo en India en toda la región de Asia
del sur y se entiende perfectamente que
otro rasgo que debe confluir para que
todo esto sea un bus un empuje en el
ámbito económico en el caso de India
incluye también un aumento de la
participación de la mujer la otra cosa
que yo veo como muy compleja en general
no solo en el caso de china porque las
tendencias de envejecimiento se
verifican en varios países y en algún
momento también van a llegar a India lo
sabemos
es el hecho de que cuando uno tiene
mayor población
de adultos mayores y de ancianos de
personas de 60 años en adelante
lentamente el perfil del sistema médico
que tiene va a ir cambiando de
enfermedades infecciosas hacia sobre
todo enfermedades degenerativas de
manera tal que no es solo la usual
presión acerca de que ya lo hemos visto
en muchos países de occidente también de
cómo se mantienen aquellas personas
que van siendo jubiladas
viven cada vez más porque la expectativa
de vida por supuesto aumenta se empieza
a discutir De qué manera vivimos mejor
no es no se trata solo de vivir más sino
de vivir mejor durante ese tiempo en que
sea prolongado la vida de manera que se
plantean una enorme cantidad de desafíos
que por supuesto también van a incidir
en la cuestión económica y probablemente
las especulaciones que hay es el mover
de lugar Cuál de los dos va a ser esa
especie de fuente de mano de obra barata
para el mundo que hasta el momento había
sido china verdad sí usted apunta algo
muy importante y muy relevante y es no
solo importa la cantidad de personas que
tenga un país y la cantidad no significa
necesariamente un crecimiento económico
al respecto Le quiero preguntar a
nuestro segundo invitado y también darle
la bienvenida a José Ignacio Martínez él
es coordinador de laboratorio de
análisis en comercio de economía y
negocios y también docente de la UNAM
quien nos acompaña desde Ciudad de
México José bienvenido y gracias por
estar con nosotros como lo comentaba Lía
no solo importa la cantidad de población
y al respecto ella mencionaba una brecha
entre los hombres y las mujeres y es que
en India A diferencia de China las
mujeres tienen menor educación en
comparación a los hombres al respecto el
Banco Mundial dice que el 66% de las
mujeres en India saben leer y escribir
esto en comparación del 96% que es el
porcentaje de China cómo esta brecha de
género puede impactar en un crecimiento
económico para India
sí Bueno aquí este los datos Más allá de
de la cuestión de de los porcentajes
proporción guardada es el mismo
comportamiento de lo que tenemos en en
China es decir hay una un proceso de
Educación tres a uno en en China decir
tres hombres por una mujer en este
aspecto aquí habría que precisar la
cuestión de cómo es que impacta el más
el desarrollo que el crecimiento a la
población lo que estamos viendo Más allá
de la cuestión que sin duda es muy
importante la parte referente a la a la
población aquí Lo importante es cómo
está el desarrollo humano entre India y
China por ejemplo así como también la
parte de infraestructura de
infraestructura social lo referente a
Salud Educación
tecnología investigación
esto sin duda es lo que potencia más a
China sobre India sin duda lo que
tenemos en India es lo referente a un
importante desarrollo tecnológico Pero
impulsado principalmente por empresas en
tanto que en China el desarrollo
tecnológico es impulsado principalmente
por el estado estamos hablando de dos
procesos
económicos democráticos sociales
totalmente
distintos y es aquí donde estaremos
viendo en los en los próximos 15-20 años
cómo es que se dan este avance
tecnológico en torno a india con
respecto a China por ejemplo lo que
tenemos en estos dos próximos años que
son los datos que yo tengo a a la mano
en torno a un crecimiento muy importante
de lo que vamos a tener en India con
relación a a China para este año
India tendrá un crecimiento de cinco
punto nueve en tanto que china un
crecimiento de cinco punto dos en 2024
China un crecimiento de cuatro punto
cinco en tanto que India un crecimiento
de seis punto tres Pero esto es
estrictamente en torno a el pib si
comparamos la parte referente a el poder
adquisitivo sin duda crece más en China
que en India vamos Esto es algo muy
importante de lo que vamos a estar
viendo en los próximos años y usted
menciona varios puntos que son
fundamentales para poder tener en cuenta
y medir ese crecimiento y usted habla
más del desarrollo y no tanto del
crecimiento poblacional yo le quiero
preguntar sobre estos elementos que nos
pone José Ignacio sobre la mesa como el
desarrollo
temas por ejemplo como la salud la
superación de la pobreza y también la
capacidad de adquisición de Cada
ciudadano que en China llega a ser hasta
cinco veces mayor que el de la población
en India al respecto según este panorama
actual India podría superar a China o
qué necesitaría en los próximos años
para lograrlo
bueno probablemente
primero saludo al al colega de México un
gusto compartir escena con usted me
parece que probablemente nos llaman la
atención estos dos países y planteamos
todo en términos de competencia porque
son los dos países más poblados del
planeta Probablemente lo mejor
teniendo cierta continuidad con lo que
acaba de señalar el colega es que sería
bueno No plantear todo en torno de la
competencia verdad en principio a pesar
de todos los problemas que hay digamos
el discurso vigente en Asia y esto lo he
dicho hace poco y hay shanker antes de
ir al punto que que mencionas el siglo
asiático va a ser tal en principios y
China India logran complementarse y
cooperar en vez de mantenerse en puntos
de tensión
claramente lo que hay en cuanto a
desarrollo humano y comparto la
pertinente lectura del colega difiere
del crecimiento no alcanza con Cuantos
más ingresen al sector laboral o cuánto
tenga de bonos demográfica India sino
que necesita ampliar la extensión del
desarrollo humano y en ese sentido hay
una deuda verdaderamente importante en
primer lugar en lo que hace a la pobreza
en general sabemos que el estado
subsidia millones de personas que no
logran todavía cubrir sus propias
necesidades eso está relacionado toda
una serie de características propias de
la población India y de mayorías
culturales Lo mismo sucede con el tema
de género y esa baja participación en el
mercado en general en el ámbito laboral
de las mujeres como te mencionaba de
manera que las si no la llamamos deudas
los que tiene India de acá hacia el
futuro son muchos dispuestos ya a ir por
ellos pero con las salvedades de ser muy
muy prudentes
pensando que toda la prospectiva que
está hecha No necesariamente tiene
presente los cambios profundos que puede
haber no yo creo que en la India hay por
lo menos Esa es mi perspectiva una
apuesta a que se va a poder llevar
adelante ese
profundo cambio que necesita hacerse
sobre todo en términos de desarrollo
humano y tiene mucho que ver con ir
sobre mentalidades que ya existen en la
población etcétera etcétera como para
incidir en la mirada sobre los roles
sociales y demás y que todo esto pueda
efectivamente contribuir al crecimiento
pero también al desarrollo real antes de
profundizar en un punto que usted
menciona y es alianza de China e India
más que una rivalidad entre estos dos
países Quiero preguntarle a José Ignacio
sobre algo que nos dice Lía y es ya
existen estas o indias ya está cerrando
esta brecha sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que desde el 2014 el actual
Primer Ministro indio narendra modi está
impulsando una inversión en la
infraestructura que si bien Todavía no
alcanza los niveles de desarrollo que
existen en China sin duda alguna en
estos últimos ocho años casi ya nueve
años
ha evolucionado sobre todo construcción
de carretera es aeropuertos etcétera es
suficiente esto para ir cerrando esta
brecha por lo menos en temas de
infraestructura
lo que bien subraya la doctora Rodríguez
a quien saluda afectuosamente es la
parte referente a la seguridad humana en
torno por supuesto al desarrollo humano
lo que tenemos en este recién pasado
lustro con relación al proyecto del plan
estratégico que impulsó India eh
tres
oscila en ocho grandes este esferas lo
que es pobreza y Urbanización que ahí
sin duda tiene una enorme déficit sumado
a salud agua saneamiento educación
empleabilidad y lo más importante lo
referente a nutrición y seguridad
alimentaria que bien planteaba Esto la
la doctora Rodríguez y lo que tenemos en
este próximo lustro es la parte
referente a este plan estratégico
2023-2027 que sin duda se estaría
esperando que India pudiera cubrir este
importante déficit en el que tiene en
torno a seguridad humana y que impulsara
esta parte referente a el desarrollo
humano Entonces es sin duda un
importante
una importante oportunidad que tiene
India de mirar hacia adentro con
relación a lo que tanto se dice en la
parte exógena de que India puede ser una
una este potencia sin duda estos
próximos 20 años que están por delante
en torno al desarrollo en torno a
seguridad humana que estaría impulsando
Nueva Delhi Pues aquí la parte referente
está en torno a la parte de El capital
intelectual así como también lo
referente a seguridad humana y es aquí
donde pues veremos Cómo se da esta
cooperación como bien señala la doctora
Rodríguez en torno a lo que puede
generarse en la parte referente a India
y y China y que son dos naciones
entrelazadas este
en la parte geopolítica pero que tienen
muchas este fricciones y sin duda Esto
va a profundizar aún más en torno a las
cinco estrategias que está ahora
impulsando el presidente Sí en tanto que
India está más enfocada hacia su parte
de desarrollo hacia adentro
usted menciona la posibilidad de un
acercamiento o las afinidades
geopolíticas que tienen India y China
además de esto demográficamente sumando
las poblaciones de los dos países tienen
más de un tercio de toda la población
del mundo y aún así tienen divisiones
históricas sobre todo en lo que compete
a sus fronteras José Ignacio Le quiero
preguntar si India y China se llegasen a
unir y afianzar sus alianzas Qué
consecuencias podría traer esto para el
resto del planeta
bueno aquí ya tenemos una prueba desde
hace ya casi 20 años en torno a la
figura del famoso este bricks no este en
principio cuatro países después se sumó
este Sudáfrica y también hay una
posición estratégica de de India con
relación a China si bien India
participan las negociaciones
al final no se suma a este muy
importante
acuerdo De igual forma
India en por ejemplo en la recién
votación que se da en la asamblea
general de Naciones Unidas para condenar
la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania
India este se abstiene de de esta este
votación al igual que que china por
supuesto Rusia vota a en contra Brasil
vota a favor Sudáfrica también se
abstiene pero India tiene un importante
acercamiento con
Washington es decir no no entra en una
fricción totalmente con con China tiene
una importante cooperación pero sin
entrar en una
alianza y esto sin duda hace ver que
ahora por ejemplo que India lidera el
g-20 pues está Estableciendo sus propios
parámetros no entra en fricción con con
India pero sí Perdón no entra en prisión
con china Pero sí tiene un importante
diálogo con Japón con Corea del Sur con
Australia por ejemplo que son sin duda
socios estratégicos en la región para
Washington entonces usted nos muestra
como estas alianzas geopolíticas y
también las divergencias que hay entre
India y China Le quiero preguntar alia
sobre las posibles consecuencias
económicas teniendo en cuenta que India
cada vez se perfila más como un destino
de distintas empresas del mundo que no
quieren estar en China por temas
diplomáticos y geopolíticos entonces
están enviando sus fábricas a India
donde la cantidad de población hace que
la mano de obra sea incluso más barata
que la del territorio chino por ejemplo
Apple abrió hace poco su primera tienda
en India la abrió la semana pasada y si
bien Ellos están ensamblando sus
celulares por ejemplo desde hace ya
muchos años sólo fue hasta el 2022 que
comenzaron a fabricar En India el Apple
el iPhone 14 es así que ya está
perfilándose esta empresa a una
producción de sus mejores celulares y
sus mejores teléfonos móviles en India y
también este país se perfila como un
sector de servicios por ejemplo
goldman sachs tiene la mayor cantidad de
personal en India cosa que ya no está
pasando tanto en China económicamente
Entonces sí puede haber una alianza o
ahí si se plantea más la rivalidad
desde mi perspectiva me parece que es
lógico que los distintos países sobre
todo de la región hacia la cual se ha
movido el eje de poder estén compitiendo
por todas estas cosas que mencionas
insisto yo trato de salir de la visión
de solo una competencia entre India y
China la segunda cosa que me parece
importante agregar a lo que decía el
colega recién es que si bien es cierto
que
India ha tenido un acercamiento con
Washington que no tuvo en otro momento
como sabemos históricamente
esto pasa sobre todo desde la gestión de
tallarín con una una prueba nuclear que
India hace durante la época del gobierno
de Clinton que lleva un acercamiento
mayor de Estados Unidos que tenía una
sensibilidad particular en su relación
con Pakistán en ese momento
es cierto también que India forma parte
de la Organización de cooperación de
Shanghai donde comparte espacio no solo
nos bri con China y también con Rusia y
yo creo que eso intenta mantener a India
fuera del perfil de alineamiento con
alguno de los lugares no India
históricamente se ha distinguido en un
primer momento por el no alineamiento
famosa posición de neru Y actualmente
por el multi alineamiento es decir India
va hacia todos aquellos este lugares
donde considera que su interés nacional
este Recibe un empuje importante Yo creo
que esa competencia se va a dar pero no
no creo que necesariamente tenga que ser
otro punto más de tensión entre ambos
países verdad Y además creo en
particular que India se ha encargado y
se encarga especialmente de decir lo
vuelvo a la figura de subramania en el
canciller de la India que fue embajador
de la India en China India no apuesta a
todos los prejuicios que hay en contra
de China no Apuesta china no apuesta a
generar más tensión
reacciona frente atenciones que le
generan pero intenta mantener un
discurso lo más Pro no tensiones de
manera tal que aunque la competencia se
dé yo creo que no tiene por qué ser un
elemento más de tensión sobre todo
Además porque India es un lugar que ha
recibido este espacio de tercerización
laboral de todo el mundo desde hace un
tiempo largo digamos no es solo el caso
de China y Es lógico que con estos
fenómenos poblacionales que estamos
mencionando se produzcan movimientos en
la región no solamente hacia china fuera
de China hacia India fuera de India se
puede decir entonces que esta posición
multi alineamiento de India de la que
usted nos habla hace que Por ende su
competencia sea menor Y eso permita su
mayor crecimiento
en mi caso particular deseo firmemente
pensar que eso va a ser así la realidad
es que seguramente el colega comparte
esta información notoria y conocida la
atención que hay en determinadas zonas
limítrofes la sensación que yo tengo es
que en realidad sirve para canalizar
distintas otras tensiones que se
manifiestan en distintas esferas donde
esa tensión no puede digamos canalizarse
solamente entonces cada vez que hay un
conflicto limítrofe pareciera que se
condensan todas las tensiones que hay en
otros ámbitos
yo soy optimista quiero pensar que ambos
países van a pensar en la conveniencia
mutua Más allá de la convivencia de
siglos
aún cuando ha habido algún
enfrentamiento digamos Creo que ambos
apuestan por una convivencia por demás
pacífica creo que además esta
neutralidad que han mantenido en las
votaciones que se en contra de la
federación rusa hablan también de eso de
tratar de no aislar algunos este agentes
internacionales ni someterlos a más
tensión creo además que ambos están
tratando de hacerse La Voz del sur
Global en todos estos aspectos Así que
yo confío en que va a primar este
interés de colaboración No tengo ánimo
de ser ingenua pero creo que de verdad
ambos tienen Claridad de que allí debe
avanzarse En esa dirección porque les
conviene ambos José Ignacio coincide
usted con este punto del día que dice
que ante la falta de fricción
internacional de India ellos decantan
esto a través de sus conflictos
nacionales sobre todo los conflictos
fronterizos
sin duda y esto
provoca que haya un permanente diálogo y
algo este muy importante ese diálogo y
sin duda es al más alto nivel de tomando
en consideración por ejemplo una figura
que ya saltaba la doctora Rodríguez en
la parte referente de el consejo de
Shanghai porque no solamente es en la en
la en las relaciones bilaterales no
solamente en este foros como eh
multilaterales Como puede ser el g20
sino una
constante un constante diálogo en torno
a figuras muy importantes
que queda aquí importante Resaltar como
es la parte de de de decir china e India
modi y Y sí constantemente se encuentran
en en foros principalmente Más allá de
lo que podemos ver en torno a por
ejemplo
la sombra de de Naciones Unidas Entonces
esto Esta esta permanente reunión de los
más altos líderes de China India pues
conlleva precisamente a impulsar este
diálogo y ello Pues Más allá de las
flexiones este geopolíticas comerciales
financieras o cooperación que pudieran
tener sin duda se trata y aquí Creo que
este sí se tiene que recoger lo que
resalta la doctora Rodríguez en la parte
de dos países del sur global que vamos
mientras escuchaba la profesora
Rodríguez pues me costaba mucho trabajo
encontrar en esta historia económica
mundial reciente cuando dos países de
del sur o lo bajo la el concepto
tradicional este subordinados habían
tenido tanta influencia como lo tienen
ahora India y
no no fue así en el en el pasado
reciente sí lo tenemos ahora antes de
entrar en la recta final de nuestro
debate lastimosamente debo despedir a
Lía Rodríguez quien debe irse profesora
Gracias por estar con nosotros y de
manera muy breve cuál sería su
conclusión sobre este crecimiento
poblacional de India
Bueno me parece que Agradeciendo
enormemente a ambos al colega y a usted
me parece que este crecimiento
poblacional de India Simplemente nos
permite pensar en nuevos
posicionamientos del sur global no
retomo lo que dice José Ignacio
absolutamente pienso que ambos países
tienen en su conciencia de diseño
geopolítico de sus propias posiciones
esa necesidad de posicionar al sur
global desde otro lugar celebro que así
sea sumo a lo que mencionaba José
Ignacio también a Brasil Por supuesto
que en este momento con Lula entiendo
que retoma precisamente todas estas
direcciones que van hacia el mismo lugar
Así que creo que este aumento de
población No necesariamente significa
una confrontación en términos de
competencia con China y espero que ambos
países con nosotros y todos los que
estamos interesados En formar parte como
es el caso de Argentina de los brics se
encaminan precisamente a ese nuevo
posicionamiento del sur global también
representado en este aumento de
población de la India Muchísimas gracias
a ambos
por acompañarnos Ahora sí retomo con
usted José Ignacio para preguntarles
sobre este punto gana entonces el sur
Global en vez de hablar de una rivalidad
entre India y China gana el sur global
con el crecimiento poblacional de estos
dos países
sin duda es el el factor este muy
importante en estos días estrictamente
hablando de población pero ambas
naciones tienen un liderazgo tecnológico
muy importante Por supuesto están en el
club de las potencias nucleares De igual
forma que tienen una presencia regional
e internacional este multilateral
importante y es algo que no se había
visto desde hace años y entonces esto
puede provocar que se dé un comercial la
persona hace un momento un importante
repunte del sur global ahora igual de lo
que tenemos este año en torno a el
liderazgo de India en el g20 también
apunta mucho a ello en incidir en desde
el sur Global en puntos que antes pues
provenían de occidente no
del G siete de Washington de Londres de
de de de de de de de de de de de de de
París incluso de Entonces ahora esto se
tiene los países del sur tienen un
importante eco con relación a lo que
vemos con India y con y con China y esto
lleva a que
estos dos países tengan un acercamiento
con otras naciones no para que coadyuven
a problemas ya sea nacionales regionales
de otros países y y decidan que tengan
eco en foros como pues como puede ser el
g20 por ejemplo
la posición que están teniendo
los concretamente India y China en la
geopolítica y en las relaciones
internacionales y también el peso que
tiene la cantidad de población de estos
países sin embargo es suficiente esto
para cambiar un poco el método y para
que la voz ya no esté en Washington
Londres Bruselas como usted decía sino
que se traslade a Nueva Delhi mumbai
Tokio y Beijing
hay que mirar hacia adentro en este caso
de India y de china en un factor de peso
que tienen por ejemplo los países Las
Naciones del g20 del g7 que es algo que
en estos próximos años tendrán que
impulsar de tanto India como China y que
es poder sostener fortalecer incluso
aumentar su demanda interna esto es al
fortalecer su demanda interna están
haciendo que tengan una producción
más más grande pero también
Que tengan un empleo y un consumo este
muy importante Por ejemplo la demanda
interna de Estados Unidos representa el
63% de su producto interno bruto ello
provoca que que todos los países quieran
venderle a Estados Unidos porque es un
país que compra no es el caso así con
India y con china cuya demanda interna
es escasa con relación al pib De igual
forma su oferta este no alcanza a cubrir
lo que están adquiriendo otros este
países Entonces es en este sentido donde
no solamente es la población per se sino
el consumo que pudieran tener estas Este
estos dos países con relación a su
población y esto estaría impulsando su
demanda Y con ello fortaleciendo su pib
pero desde adentro Sí usted plantea algo
que hemos tratado en el debate y es la
relación entre lo que ocurre
internamente en un país y como esto
media en sus relaciones internacionales
y en su comercio internacional en el
caso de India Le quiero preguntar qué
tanto incide y que tanto impacto tiene
por ejemplo la política de narendra modi
de una de relegar a los musulmanes y de
cada vez cerrar más sus derechos de
imponer unas políticas que apuntan más a
la censura y en todo este crecimiento
poblacional Cuál es el efecto que puede
tener por ejemplo en los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres
internamente Cuál es la situación de
India muy brevemente y esto sin duda es
lo que está en por ejemplo en la tercera
generación de Derechos Humanos en lo
referente a mayor este libertades lo
cual
esto puede provocar enormes sanciones a
a India en ciertos este países con
ciertas empresas y ciertos grupos este
sociales de el mundo en el sentido de
que se violentan este derechos humanos
en en India esto también
en en en China por supuesto también esto
ocurre en en Estados Unidos solamente
que son estas naciones de occidente las
que establecen los parámetros de
derechos humanos con esto sin duda algo
que se tiene que trabajar y es
estrictamente cuestiones culturales de
lo que se tiene en India en respecto a
lo que se menciona en torno a mujeres en
torno musulmanes y es algo que sin duda
tiene que India Precisamente en de Cara
a una a un mejor apuntamiento de la
tercera generación de Derechos Humanos
José Ignacio muy brevemente en 30
segundos cuál sería entonces su
conclusión sobre este crecimiento
poblacional de India
ese crecimiento de población se debe
acompañar con conocimiento intelectual
con recursos humanos con seguridad
humana y desarrollo humano José Ignacio
Martínez Gracias por acompañarnos aquí
en el debate de France 24
Muchas gracias por la invitación y a
ustedes Muchas gracias por sintonizarnos
les agradezco En nombre del equipo
técnico la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncell y la
producción de invitados la tuvo Tania
Herrera ustedes pueden dejar sus
comentarios en redes y todas las
preguntas serán resueltas sigan con más
aquí en France 24
[Música]